[Music]
don't aim to be the best
aim to be the only
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast
today I'm speaking with Kevin Kelly a
true Pioneer in the world of technology
and media here to help us make better
sense of our confusing presence and to
share an admittedly optimistic gaze into
the future in the end it's only going to
be the optimists who are going to shape
our culture so you want to be on the
side of The Optimist to make your vision
possible Kevin is the co-founder of
Wired Magazine widely recognized as the
Bible of the digital age he's also a
renowned futurist and author a public
speaker whose insights into the world of
technology and its impact on society
have been widely sought after and deeply
deeply influential over the course of
his career Kevin has authored several
seminal books including out of control
the new biology of machines social
systems and the economic world and what
technology wants he has also been a
prolific writer and commentator on a
wide range of subjects related to
technology culture and society and has
been a regular contributor to
Publications including the New York
Times The Economist and Scientific
American in today's conversation Kevin
shares a hopeful vision of the future of
technology and how it will continue to
transform our lives and transform our
world for the better in addition we
discuss Kevin's latest book which is
called excellent advice for living
wisdom I wish I'd known earlier and the
book as predicted is excellent
but before we dive in this episode is
brought to you today by Roca now I get
asked constantly about the glasses that
I wear on the show Rich what are those
things that you got on your head well
they're Roca and in my case right now
I'm wearing the Hamilton frames I love
them everything Roca makes is super high
performance incredibly light great
Optics they have wide array of amazing
Styles and they just never ever slip off
your face and I'm going to be sharing a
bit more about Roka later but for now
all you need to know is this is a
powerful exchange about where our new
world of technology is heading and my
hope is that Kevin's words help brighten
how we're thinking about a future that
is so rapidly evolving and above all
helps to prepare all of us for the
inevitable changes on the horizon so
without further Ado please enjoy me and
Kevin Kelly
[Music]
well Kevin it's an absolute Delight to
meet you thank you so much for taking
the time to do this to coming down I've
been looking forward to this for a very
long time and uh I gotta tell you I'm a
little bit uh I'm a little bit like
nervous my outline is like 10 miles long
there's just so many things I'd like to
talk to you about I'm sure we'll get to
five percent of them today but I guess
my head is is just jumbled with too many
ideas but I can't uh I can't begin
without acknowledging this collection of
extraordinary books that are on the
table right now if you're watching on
YouTube you can see them this series of
three volumes uh called Vanishing Asia
these beautiful coffee table books
chronicling uh the photographs that
you've taken over many decades of your
experience in in Asia and we were just
chatting before the podcast uh you know
kind of going through them and it's
really quite a spectacular kind of
um
uh I guess you know history of not just
um certain cultures but also I think in
many ways and I've heard you talk about
this kind of an important document of
Disappearing uh you know aspects of of
these cultures that you know are quickly
diminishing and and part of your
motivation being like I just want to
capture these on film before they you
know they become something of a bygone
era yeah so thank you for having me and
it's a real joy to be able to share some
of this work
and other things that I'm up to but the
vanishing Asia books that you're talking
about
have been a 50-year compulsion I guess
really honestly what it was to kind of
document these Vanishing ceremonies and
traditions that I have witnessed and
I've had sort of the pleasure of
witnessing in some cases because they're
no longer being done at least the way
that they were and um I again had the
privilege of seeing the world at a
moment when it was very easy for someone
like me with no money to get to these
really remote places that had not
changed very much
now they have or kind of on a future
trajectory like the rest of us
um so this was my passion project to to
document these things and
uh we did a Kickstarter program to help
make copies of them available and um
I'm just really glad that I can share it
with other people who might enjoy them
as much as I do so your relationship
with Asia goes all the way back to your
youth right like you have cut a very
interesting and unique path uh sort of
you know orthogonal to you know the
traditional Notions of what a young
person is is meant to do in order to be
upwardly mobile and kind of you know
headed off into the Into the Wilderness
with your backpack uh to explore the
world in a very kind of Jack Kerouac
sort of way
yeah I it was very
maybe say uh unintentional I I didn't
have grand plans
I was inspired by the whole earth
catalog in high school to
it gave me permission to kind of invent
my life to invent your own life that you
had permissions because until that
moment I hadn't really met anybody who
wasn't following the same pers you know
progression of things High School
College work for a corporation
um the idea of being able to do
something was really not an alternative
the hippies were beginning to kind of
Pioneer one of those and I said okay I
think I see other people that admire who
are going a different direction that
means it's possible and I wound up in
Asia without the faintest clue about
what it was or I
never eaten Chinese food never held
Chopsticks it was very parochial at the
time and so it kind of just blew my mind
in terms of the possibilities and the
the otherness and the differences were
very very prominent and it was very
welcoming and it was very cheap and so I
had a home there to explore and that's
what I did for my 20s basically yeah so
it was an extent it wasn't just taking a
gap year you were there for back and
forth for foreign
well you know if if they'd had a gap
year at that time if that was a thing or
even an internship you know I would have
done that and probably gone back to
college but because there wasn't I
dropped out and I roamed around Asia and
I say kind of tongue-in-cheek that you
know after a decade or so I uh I gave I
awarded myself an honorary degree in
Asian studies because I felt like okay I
know I know something but those
experiences are are or or or were truly
formative in in your world view and also
in the advice that you now dispense to
younger people about what's important
what you should be thinking about what
you shouldn't be concerned about in
terms of pursuing you know a meaningful
life yeah the way I might reduce it now
all those years of experience and travel
is in your 20s
try and spend some time doing something
that looks nothing like success that's
kind of crazy stupid weird orthogonal
unprofitable
um crazy
um maybe dangerous
um and and
that experience is likely as
unsuccessful as it might look then to
become the Touchstone for your success
later on it will become really really
important to you if you're able to do
that
yeah I uh I did the opposite and uh and
regret it deeply
um I wish that I had had such a
broadening experience in my youth
especially now in my you know mid to
late 50s looking back thinking why
didn't I do that right but when you're
in that moment and all the social
pressure and all the messaging that you
know you're on the receiving end of is
is is sort of incentivizing you to do
the opposite so you really have to you
know Buck your tradition and yeah
there's a lot of you know parental and
social you know pressure that that
military against this so it's really
really a courageous act in fact the more
kind of the more successful you are in
school the more there is a kind of
outward pressure for you to follow that
and take advantage of your kind of um
your good scores your good grades but I
actually um my son and my kids went
through the same thing college prep and
all this stuff and they were on their
way to college I went to college and
that was another story but I did talk
him out of it I did so so it's like the
kids always do the opposite right
exactly so my wife is Chinese and so
she's you know education all the way
yeah and it's the one thing we disagreed
about because I was off to the side
saying you know you don't really have to
go to college but here's the thing is
like if if you have an alternative if
you have a program you want to do if you
have a travel if you have something you
want to work on
make it a program for us and we'll
support that
but if you don't have that then you have
to go to college and to my surprise all
three went to college and it's like that
would not have been what I would have
done but they went to college but after
that
our son was doing some things he went to
get a job and he said look
you need to spend at least a year
goofing off and doing nothing
because you for an entire life you've
been like getting grades and working
hard and all this kind of stuff and
you've graduated it's like you have to
goof off for a while
and so he was thinking about getting an
MFA and art and then so he's decided to
give himself his own MFA to make a
little program where he did art for a
year and then wrote a thesis at the end
and made a kind of like a PhD project
out of it and gave it to his other art
professors at school to read and so he
awarded himself an MFA which I thought
that was exactly what he needed to do
yeah and that was so good for him in
many many ways it's so hard to see when
you're at that age how important that
sort of goofing off time is because it
does feel like squandered time when your
peers are kind of escalating up the
corporate ladder or or what have you and
there's an inherent tension or conflict
between the incentives of our modern
developed World which are pushing us in
a certain direction to become productive
and
um you know independent financially and
and and contributory But ultimately you
know and I'm sure you would agree and
you're a product of this the most
interesting people that have the most to
contribute are the people that that that
took that you know less beaten path and
went deep into exploration and spent the
time in rumination and experience to
come out of it more robust and with a
set of of seemingly you know not
connected skills that somehow later in
life all congeal to make them uh you
know kind of truly the only person who
can speak to a certain issue or or an
expert in a field that maybe nobody even
thought would be right right it's it's
really clear right now that the major
engine
of wealth and I would also uh suggest
personal happiness is is
um being able to think different that's
that's the engines and when we're when
we're all connected 24 hours a day
around the world with our little devices
the the true value is being able to
think a little differently that's the
source of innovation that's how you make
great things that's how you make great
art
and um anything that can help you think
differently including AI which we'll
talk about later I'm sure
but travel and other experiences
doing having uh reading different books
than other people read I mean there's
lots of ways to do that but you want to
really cultivate that ability to think
differently
in a world where everybody's connected
together all the time and so I I would
argue yes
um
Zig Well everybody's zagging you know
and um try and do something different
and you know travel is a tremendously
efficient and productive and inexpensive
way to do that and
um taking time off goofing off is
another great way to do that sabbatical
sabbaths
um it was another great way so there's
that's the assignment really for most
people is is to have different ideas to
approach things differently you're going
to need help doing that yeah and I think
that we
frame this backwards in the sense that
when I have enough money or when I
retire or when I have the the luxury of
time right right then I will indulge
that you know instinct to go see the
world right the truth you know and
through your experience it's the it's
like when you don't have money and you
have tons of time that's the time to do
it and we think we can't afford it but
right right your example and I I don't
know that it's that different today is
that there are incredibly cheap ways to
do this you can work when you're there
you can work and then go there right
right live cheaply in one of the pieces
of advice that that I always give to
young people that that I wish had been
given to me when I was younger was have
experiences Live Lean so that you can
have choices and you know indulge in
your creativity and your curiosity
because
uh this idea that at 18 or at 20 you're
supposed to know you know what it is
that you're going to do in the world and
and lock in on that is absolutely
ludicrous right yeah there's there's so
many things about that there was a I
think Ralph Potts talked about this
story which um I might have been in the
movie of a sky who's going to Wall
Street and he's kind of hates Wall
Street whatever but he's got to make a
lot of money and he was explaining to
his friend that he wanted to work for
maybe one or two more years so he could
have his money his fortune whatever it
is and then he could buy a motorcycle
and drive it across China
and any we were just we laughed The
Travelers laugh because you could work
at McDonald's for a year or half a year
and earn enough money to buy a
motorcycle and ride across China it's
it's not a matter of money uh it's like
it's like it's the time and that was the
thing that I got traveling when I was
younger with very little money at all
was meeting some people on these tours
and stuff I had a lot of money and
having a guy
um tell me
that he envied me
because I was taking my time you know I
was I was on the hiking in the Himalayas
right and I was going on and they were
in a kind of a forced little thing and
very controlled and it's like he was
saying I wish I could have been you I
wish I did that when I was young I wish
I had that kind of time and here's
here's a rich guy I was like oh I get it
yeah yeah it's like the rich have money
the wealthy have time
and it's much easier to be wealthy than
rich
because you can control you you have
time that you're given and so
um that's the thing I started to aim for
was that kind of
having the wealth of time and control of
my time
I'm pretty sure that that story comes
from Ralph potts's book vagabonding and
it's lifted out of the movie Wall Street
it's Charlie Sheen right saying you know
talking about what he's going to do when
he when he when he makes it big right
right right yeah yeah it's like you
could do that now you can do that now
right well you know that's that's a very
common Trope in our family my kids sort
of have heard many times but very you
know every couple years I sit them down
I have three kids and I say um I have a
magic wand I'm gonna give you a billion
dollars
but only if you tell me what you're
gonna do with it right you get what are
you gonna do with a billion dollars and
they'll go through the kind of lists and
what they're maybe they're imagining
they're young adults and stuff and you
know I would maybe buy a house or
something and I would go on a trip
somewhere and I would have this I said
okay
um that you haven't you haven't spent
any of your money yet right because in
six months that will entirely interest
will pay back and you're back with a
billion dollars now what are you gonna
do oh well maybe uh I'm making something
up maybe I'll start a little shop
selling um knitwear or I want to do a
little
um daycare center or whatever it is and
it's like okay
you don't need a billion dollars for
that
so this idea I mean most people's dreams
or not a matter of they're not gated by
money
the Gated by other things and
um it's very clear in my own experiences
that
that that dream of wanting to work to
have the fortune to do it is is that's a
really convoluted and unnecessary way
around getting what you want your dreams
to do right but it's the byproduct of a
culture that we live in that is you know
sort of pushing this narrative or
incentivizing this notion that extreme
wealth is the path to happiness yeah uh
and that you know material accumulation
and uh and and and comfort and luxury
are the keys that will unlock that thing
that's missing in your life and fill
that desperate hole in your soul uh and
it's only through stories of people who
have you know explored that to the very
you know Nth Degree and have reported
back
and despite their reporting back we
still don't believe them exactly that's
how powerful this is right right you
know I think that it it demands you know
some some extreme counterpart
programming in in the form of you know
kind of your experience and the
experience of others who can report back
that in fact after you meet your your
base needs through income it's not that
money isn't important
um that it's truly you know experience
and broadening your horizons and finding
a way to contribute and and and link
your your life path to some kind of
purpose or meaning
um that extends beyond your your your
ego and kind of you know
self-gratification instincts that you
will find the happiness that all those
other false promises fail to deliver on
yeah it's I've had again the honor and
privilege to hang out with some
billionaires and
um what's remarkable is is that they're
still asking themselves what they want
to do when they grow up right I mean
which is good which is good right
exactly but it's just saying that that
their billions actually haven't
really help them do that alone in fact
it's added another burden it's become
another job it's another whole set of
things that they have to
to overcome
so I mean having a billion dollars is
something you overcome and it's a real
issue about thinking about your kids and
what impact it has on their kids which
is very very strange in many ways and so
um so so I've concluded this is not in
my advice book but this is a piece of
advice I have now which is my advice is
if you can all help it do not earn a
billion dollars
okay please give me a favor I'll try to
avoid that dude exactly you'll be much
have do not earn a billion dollars well
the real calculus is is the money that
you're earning creating freedom for you
or is it creating you know a a more you
know calcified prison for yours exactly
right because it can do either of those
things I'm sure there are billionaires
who've been able to figure out how to
you know create Freedom out of that for
themselves maybe not I don't know I
don't I don't even know that I know any
billionaires but you do but yeah
um you know if you're if your wealth can
provide that then okay yeah but if it's
just creating misery for yourself then
what's the point right and so that that
level of getting what you need comes way
before a billion dollars is this what
I'm saying it's like you know and so at
that point if a billion dollars it is a
burden it is something that really
weighs on the people who have it it's
kind of like Fame it's my advice it's
just you really don't want to be famous
either if you just read any biography
about a famous really famous person it's
another type of imprisonment and most
the people who are really really famous
really regret that that is because they
have to deal with it all the time and
it's a real um what's the word again uh
hinders hinders them in many ways and so
it's not Freedom at all and I and it's
the same thing so so
um you really want to focus on this is
my piece my favorite piece of advice
from the book which is don't aim to be
the best
aim to be the only right and that only
is where you'll you'll be much more
satisfied happy
you'll probably have enough
um and and that is that is the route
it's the the billions is another
person's
success
that's that should not be your success
it's it's it's someone else's movie If
you're trying to make a billion dollars
you want to go you want to be the star
on your own movie sure but explain that
a little bit more because
the idea of being the only isn't
intimidating yes Prospect right like how
do you become the only the only at what
and I think becoming the only at
anything even if it's the most obscure
thing on the planet does require again
back to what we were talking about
earlier you know kind of being
contrarian or cutting Against the Grain
and and doing things a little bit
differently and I I don't know that
everyone is is sort of cut out for that
yeah so so
um first of all it is a high bar it is a
very very high bar and the second thing
in my experience in in both my own life
and looking at other people it will take
most of your life to arrive there
there might be the really weird freakish
person who's born
and has a clear idea of what they're
really great at that nobody else can do
and
um they go for it but most of us it's um
it's a long and Meandering winding road
with lots of detours and right turns and
setbacks and turnarounds and everything
else to to arrive there and you actually
don't never arrive you're always on that
journey of trying to figure out what
what it is about yourself that is
special and unique
um but but it doesn't
um
and okay so so there is there is a
paralysis I've seen in young people it's
like I don't know what I'm passionate
about I don't know and so I can't really
start I can't keep my 100 until I know
what that is and
um I become convinced
um that the
um the proper ways to start is to master
something
and in that Mastery that becomes a
platform that you begin to kind of move
towards discovering what passion is a
product of action exactly it's not the
other way around exactly waiting around
until you're struck with what you're
passionate about as a as a precursor to
action is the way most people think
about it and that just leads to
paralysis and like a protracted period
of confusion exactly so you
you almost and and it doesn't matter
where you start because that's not where
you're going to be ending and that's
true again if you look any remarkable
person that you admire
they didn't start there they arrived at
their and the more kind of distinctive
unique special and only they are the
more likely they started way away from
where they actually discovered what they
were good at and so don't doesn't really
don't be concerned about where you're
starting as long as you're moving
forward in that way of really
deliberately trying to get better you'll
arrive in in your in the right direction
yeah I I think age and wisdom really
gives you Clarity on this perspective
though when I look at your life
obviously when you headed out to Asia at
a young age or you know even when you
were working at the whole earth catalog
and founding wired like none of those
experiences could have uh you know
created Clarity that you would be this
thought leader and futurist and
pontificator on you know everything I
don't even know how to qualify like what
it is that you do but what you do is
very unique and you are a one of one
right right all of those experiences
Assemble bold to produce this you know
individual who has a certain perspective
that has value that nobody else has and
you know in my own experience I've done
a number of things that have led me to
this place none of which I whiteboarded
or predicted or kind of scoped out or
set as a goal they're the byproduct of
trying different things and failing and
all the like what I find though is that
it's very difficult to penetrate the
mindset of a 20-something year old
person with this that that perspective
almost has to be earned and an example
of that
is I had um rain Wilson on the podcast
like a year ago he's actually coming
back later this week who is he was he
was an actor on that show The Office
whatever he was like 20s are for [__]
around don't even worry about it what
are you guys so stressed out about
you're supposed to be you're supposed to
go out and fail and like who cares right
and that like we shared that video and
it went crazy viral and it was a pretty
close 50 50 split in like how people
responded to it like people saying I
Amen on the one hand and a lot of people
being like you don't understand my life
yeah like how dare you I can't afford
this this that's a very privileged
perspective and you know I would and and
not to be you know like I'm I'm
sensitive to people varying you know
socioeconomic conditions Etc I don't
know people you know people's lives but
you know I think the wisdom of that
still holds true but I think it's my
point being that you know for a lot of
young people it's it's threatening to
hear that it's hard to hear that so like
step into the idea that that might be a
possibility is is scary and it does do
you know you know require kind of
grappling with with certain realities
um
and so I guess my question is like is it
different net I mean we live in a
different time now than when you did it
is it harder to do that now is it still
possible like how would you speak to
that young person who had kind of uh uh
you know a strong visceral negative
reaction to that yeah type of advice so
I I too am sensitive and I'm thinking
not just of the people in this country
but the people all over the world sure
in Asia where I spent a lot of time
where this is a very real thing and they
have far more constraints on their lives
even than say a typical American in
terms of their parents and their
expectations about what they do and
stuff so the way the way I would say
that is that um as a first pass is that
if it is all possible for you the more
you can do that the better so so I would
say yes there are going to be people
whose lives do not allow them that
luxury
and that's unfortunate and that's
something we would like to change that's
something that for me what prosperities
brings which is that we have more
choices
uh and you know for most the people in
The Villages of the Asian countries that
I have spent in
they had even fewer options than that
they they were if they stayed in the
village they were going to be the Farmer
they didn't have any chance to become
the only
so
um so yes I think it is privilege in
that sense but what we want is we want
to spread that privilege around to more
people but if you have any chance to do
that
in some ways you're cheating Us by not
taking advantage of that that's why you
do art you do art in part for yourself
but also because
because you owe it to us for that's
that's the deal and the deal meaning
that you're alive and you have this
chance and you have a genius and nobody
else has and if you can share that with
us we all benefit so so I would say yes
it it may not be that everybody can take
advantage of it but it's still true to
the extent that it is possible for you
um it'll be better for you and for the
world if you did
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rocas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roka.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
your newest book excellent advice for
living
um
this is sort of uh this is a really
interesting book because on the one hand
it's incredibly simple but every idea
that that you know shows up on every
page
the more you consider these very concise
phrases the more profound you realize
they are it's almost a tweet storm right
this is like a tweet thread in the form
of a book right condensed wisdom over
the course of your life uh you know
offered up in in a in very digestible
form you can open it up to any page and
just you know consume one thought and
think about it you know for the day so
talk a little bit about like why you
decided to write this book and uh what
your kind of intention for it is
yeah um
so I began the book not with the idea of
making a book but um I have been in the
habit of writing down
bits of wisdom
in to a little compact
proverb of some sort to help me remember
it
so I can repeat it to myself so a piece
of advice I picked up at Whole Earth
from one of the editors Ann Herbert was
um this was I don't know 40 years ago
she said look you know whenever you are
be invited to do something into the
future like to have a meeting to go
speak somewhere to have coffee with
someone to make a presentation ask
yourself what did I do if it was
tomorrow morning
and that was like oh man that was so
useful that was so so powerful because
that's what I would do is I would get an
invitation to do something that's
essentially great but wait wait wait
wait
um when I want to do this if it was
tomorrow morning right and then if it's
if it's far enough out on the calendar
like I'll agree to anything exactly yeah
but you but it'll be soon enough it'll
be tomorrow morning and you're like I
don't really want to do this so This
future projection was very very useful
and so I reduced it to that little thing
and I would repeat that to myself and
there was another piece of advice that I
learned from and I don't even remember
where because
um these things come and go but um was
that if I lost something in my household
and I couldn't find it and then I
finally found it my flashlight whatever
it was
and I would go to put it back the piece
of advice was oh no no don't put it back
where you found it put it back where you
first looked for it
um because that first impulse next time
you can look for it that's where I'm
gonna find it so I repeat that to myself
and so I decided I was writing these
down and then I decided that um
I should keep doing that for my kids
because I have three kids and we are our
style of parenting was based on my
experience which was I didn't really pay
much attention to it my parents said I
pay a lot of attention to what they did
so that was our style which was we
didn't preach or even
give advice to our kids very much
it was all through what we did
and but it's writing these things down
there were like a lot of them that I
actually wished I had known earlier so
I'd say well
it's time we should
give some of those write them down and
and and give them to the kids and so
that's what I was starting to do as I
wanted to write down things
first for my son to
um things that I wished I'd known
earlier in these little compact
tweetable things and that's how I began
and I put out 68 of them on my 68th
birthday and I shared it with
my kids and they loved it and I then
shared with my greater family and went
out from there and it kind of ricocheted
around the internet and did its thing
and I was encouraged to do more of them
and I kept doing them on my birthday and
then there was a point in which they
were kind of scattered all over the
place and I thought they needed to be in
between covers so they could hand it to
a young person and that's the origin
yeah it's great
um we talked earlier about don't be the
best be the only that's certainly one
entry in here and I wrote down a couple
that kind of uh you know stuck out uh to
me I mean they really are like you know
these just really kind they on the
surface like really simple thoughts
right don't keep making the same
mistakes try to make new mistakes like
okay well what what are you actually
saying there right like we should go
make mistakes like you have permission
to fail and you should fail
um it's only problematic when you keep
doing the same thing over and over and
over again right right
um I love this other one productivity is
often a distraction don't aim for better
ways to get through your tasks as
quickly as possible instead aim for
better tasks that you never want to stop
doing right and that's something again I
took me a long time to kind of realize
that because you'd read all these
product productivity books and stuff
you're getting things done and all that
kind of stuff but no no actually
what makes me happy is is spending
inordinate amount of times things
um never getting done so I I make one
piece of art every day I did that for
last year sharing that the AI art that
you sure
but I'm but I spent an incredible amount
of time it's like I'm not trying to
reduce the amount of time I'm trying to
increase the amount of time I spend that
because I just enjoy it so much right
um another one is uh and this gets into
kind of segwaying into the the broader
picture of who you are uh over the long
term the future is decided by optimists
yes to be an optimist
you don't have to ignore the multitude
of problems we create you just have to
imagine how much our ability to solve
problems improves right
so you know this gets at the heart uh
you know kind of the core of like who
you are as a human being
um you know your many things but most
notably you know sort of the
reductionist term that gets associated
with you as futurist I don't know how
you feel about that
um
but uh you know that is the thing like
you have this capacity to
um
communicate and understand the present
moment and how it relates to the near
and and short-term future and you have
the facility to kind of communicate
around that that that is rare and I
think instructive
um but I think you know as we've already
demonstrated it's it's broader than that
because you have lived this very broad
life you know well-traveled deeply
considered
um clearly somebody who who has devoted
copious amount of time to pondering
questions big and small uh and and from
that you know extracting what the short
and long-term future will hold and how
to deploy our our attention what we
should be worried about thinking about
what we shouldn't be worried about
Etc all of which you know is is sort of
condensed and Consolidated in this
latest book but the overarching theme to
all of this is this unbridled optimism
and and this is something that I
personally struggle with especially in
our in our very current moment where
things have you know seem to be
happening quite rapidly and you know
from my perspective at times spinning a
little bit out of control so talk me
through your perspective of the let's
talk about the current moment first
before we get into futurecasting sure
like how are you making sense of what is
actually happening right now we're right
you know in this moment of chat GPT 4
being introduced to the world and and
there's a global conversation
um that's occurring you know at a very
broad level around artificial
intelligence what it means what it
portends you know what it's what it's
doing for us what our fears are Etc so
you know where are you at with all this
yeah so um
uh
I think you're right to kind of pinpoint
the optimism as a pivot and I think um I
would say that I am generally by
temperament genetically proposed to you
know to be optimistic
but that actually I have actually
um
but also thinks optimism is something
you can learn particularly as a child
and I have actually
um deliberately
um become even more optimistic
as I get older and um where does that
come as I said there's a natural
temperament but it comes from other
places
um I don't spend much time trying to
predict the future I am trying to
predict the present
just to figure out what exactly is
happening going on right now and to
really look at that and and I think
that's half of the half of the president
is just getting this understanding
what's happening right now and um but I
but I have noticed over time
that um
optimistic views tended to be more
correct
than not so the the people who like if
so the more I became interested in the
future the more I would read the past
and become interested in history which I
hated in high school I just had no
interest whatsoever I was turned off by
I just didn't see it but as I started to
travel more as I started to have to work
in the technology which was changing so
fast the more interesting and more
interesting I became in history and the
more I read it and now I just mostly
read history and what I get from that in
my own experiences traveling in these
under undeveloped and developing
um places was the
acknowledgment of progress
acknowledging that there actually has
indeed been progress material progress
as well as moral progress over time and
that when we when people talk about the
this current time and the craziness of
it
I have to say
you can only say that if you have no
idea of history and how crazy
things how crazy politics were in the US
say in the 1890s or whatever it was we
just
it's almost beyond belief I mean think
about the fact that there was a vice
president who shot his political upload
it was like and they went back like
dueling yeah like Hamilton I was like
that's like that's totally you know I
mean and we disagreed to the point that
we were killing each other during the
Civil War so so in that sense
if you history gives you a bit more
perspective to the current problem
that's all I'm saying it puts it into
perspective to say well actually
we've had periods like that in the past
and what happened so
um that sense of history and progress I
think informs a lot of how I look at
things and
um that's a fundamental
um orientation so so the little
heuristic that I have that I play in my
head which is that if we can create
one percent more than we destroy every
year
then we can have progress because that
one percent can accumulate that's the
genius of compounded interest if you can
have one percent betterment so one
percent if you're going to be one
percent better than we are bad
that's all we need and that little tiny
bit is kind of invisible in the world
one percent difference in betterment it
you know it means like 49 and a half
percent of everything is crap and
terrible it may be harmful so it's
really hard to see that little
difference of of one percent but we can
see it in retrospect if we look behind
and I had the privilege of being in a
time machine and going back to the
behind going back to where we were and
really living there in a futile time
with feudal relationships and feudal
technology and very little and so I know
deep down where we've come from and what
how far we've come and that sense of
like well here's what we get yeah we got
some new problems but man we also have
some new good things and it's so much
easier for us to imagine
going forward the problems and all the
ways in which it doesn't work that's
entropy it's harder to imagine the one
or two ways things do work
the way things work are much more
improbable
than the way things break that's again
that's the rule of Entry that's the
second law of Thermodynamics that's
never been broken which is that the ways
the the ways in which things cannot work
and degrade are far far than the few
ways that it can work because things at
work are more improbable part of what we
want to be is we want to be improbable
beings another way we could say like
don't be the best be the only is be the
most improbable person possible
hmm okay and so that in probability is
biased
to things breaking down to there being
more
more ways we can imagine things not
working and the difficulty in trying to
imagine ways that do work
and that comes back again to why we
should be optimistic which is that
because it's so hard
to
um to make things that work they'd
really work inadvertently
we have to kind of imagine that they
could work and to believe that they
could work in order to make them work
so there were a bunch of people who saw
the Star Trek Communicator and said
I want to make that
I want that I want that to be real I
believe that that could be real
there are lots of ways which could not
work and there were many tries the
Newton and others that failed
because it was easier to fail than not
that's the general rule but there were
people who really believed that that
would work and it'd be good and so that
belief that imagination of imagining
what it is that we want and believing
that it's possible
is those are the people who make the
things and so in the end when we look
back all the good things we have were
made by people who believed that they
were possible and believed that they
could be made and so going forward
that's going to be the same is is that
it's
um
if we want to have a society that really
works since full of Technology we need
to imagine an optimistic view of it and
believe that we can actually reach that
I'm completely with you on the belief
that we need to you know have a sense
that the world can be better and and aim
our intentionality and our and our our
hard work you know in that direction but
on the subject of like the world
becoming one percent better or you know
kind of looking around and seeing you
know what's happening is not is is that
not a factor of the lens through which
you choose to perceive the world because
you can you can look at the Star Trek
Communicator and and then you know you
know look at the iPhone Etc and
celebrate that or you can look at the
accelerating rate of of you know species
Extinction and climate degradation and
the widening gap between the Haves and
the have-nots and and the sort of you
know to your point about uh you know
understanding history looking at the
history of of past Empires and the rise
and fall and the The Arc of these and
and to try to identify where where you
know the United States might fall on
that Arc you know I think you might
agree that we perhaps we're on the
decline of that and what does that mean
in terms of the global you know sort of
power structure and where we sit in the
world and what we should be focused on
and what not like so there's a choice of
perspective that comes into play here
um that that sort of tempers my you know
my my uh you know ability to just jump
on the optimistic bandwagon so so you're
right and my perspective is decidedly
in this in this respect not American
sure there are three there are 350
Americans between China and India alone
there's 10 times the number of people
increasingly
what they think about the world will
matter more than what we think about the
world so I so I look at the world in a
kind of a Global Perspective and I think
that's where we're moving to and that's
part of what the US is still struggling
with is this idea that it is a super
power and it doesn't want to be uh it
doesn't want to be a globalist I mean
this is sort of like the ultimate insult
right now which is crazy to me because
look people this is where we're headed
to we're headed to a planetary economy
we're going to have planetary governance
that's the direction that we have a
planetary machine right now so on
average globally
um
if you do the Obama test which is I'll
let you you you're going to be born at
some year in a random assignment of sex
and gender and place in society where do
you want to be what year do you want to
be born in there's all there's not a
year in the past
that's a better deal than right now
that's the Stephen Pinker kind of notion
of this is the best time to be this is
the best time that's this is the
acknowledgment of progress and so
um yes there are there are new
technologies the more powerful they are
the more powerful problems they will
produce right explain that a little bit
like this this idea of fracturing the
binary between we're either moving
towards a Utopia or a dystopia yeah so
that is and and by the way
um almost every single really good
science fiction movie about the future
is dystopian
because they just make greater stories I
mean the the people writing stories
really know how to tell stories and
they're mostly about
um this dystopian world there's very
very few about and a world that you
would want to live in on this planet and
um that's a problem for us but that
choice of and then Utopias we we just
first of all I don't think they're a
good idea I don't think we'd want to be
happy there and they're impossible
but this idea of no other choice and I
coined a term called protopia which is
this idea that we can have a world
that's a little tiny bit better this
going back to the little Delta
incrementally a little bit better we're
kind of creeped towards betterment over
time it's not Problem free in fact the
problems are the propulsion for progress
and that world of um inching forward
where we have new problems as well as
new technologies
that's the protopian world and I think
um that is a
so that's a more achievable that's a
more achievable destination part of that
definition is also driven by human
agency and choice of course that's the
thing like right we are we are creating
this in real time yes right I wrote a
book called The Inevitable and the
inevitability that I talk about in the
book which is technological
inevitability is that um
things like once you invent what's a
civilization anywhere in the Galaxy
invents electrical wires and things
they'll begin to invent electric motors
and once and once they have electrical
signals they'll have radio so it's like
there's a sequence of things which will
inevitably come up once you have you
know electrical networks you'll have the
internet of some sort sooner or later on
your planet
now and the AI will come so the AI
coming is sort of inevitable but what's
not inevitable is the um character of
the AIS and the plural there are many
types and um who owns them how they
governed is international or national is
it commercial or non-commercial is it
prop non-profit is it open source or
close there are so many different
attributes that we have to decide and
can decide and have the choices decide
and all those choices make humendous
difference to us so the AIS are coming
but the character of the AIS and the
system is is entirely our choice
collectively so we do have tremendous
choices even in the fact that this stuff
at the large scale is inevitable but
that choice can only drive so much of
the landscape of consequence in the
sense that there will always be
especially with these emerging
Technologies a landscape of unintended
constant yes and by their very nature
they are unintended despite our best
efforts to curtail them or to you know
instill them with a certain ethic that
we think is going to you know you know
be the best for right so Humanity in
addition to the unintended negative
consequences they're also unintended
benefits
mm-hmm and that's sort of what we see
happening right now with gbt and the
image AI generators and that to me is a
thrill is that
lots of things that they're doing the
inventors of them had no idea that they
could do right and within 24 hours yes
there are use cases popping up that
nobody thought of nobody thought one day
right and that's the thing I discovered
in researching the history of technology
is that the first of all several things
one is simultaneous independent
invention is the norm
because
um the idea of the heroic inventor is
just totally wrong it's a Hollywood
invention but the idea is is is that
um ideas and inventions are networks of
things there are many many parts and if
someone didn't invented someone else
right behind them would which means that
um
also the inventors of them don't know
what they're good for I I tell a story
in one of my books about Thomas Edison
who was inventor of the phonograph the
wax cylinder recording things and he
that evening or day or whatever it was
he made a list of all the things he
thought this device would do
and the number one thing which actually
he he did and then and and it's um
somebody been recovered was to record
the last words of the dying
for Prosperity so this was a this was
like a really freaky thing was like oh
in the future you could hear Aunt Albert
talking
and he made other ideas and number 10
down at the bottom was you might be able
to use it for music right
so he had no idea yeah no concept no
concept of what it is and the only way
we are going to figure out these new
technologies particularly as a
complicated is through use it's through
use we can't think it's a term I call
thinkism thinkism is this idea that we
can decide and figure out things and
salute and have Solutions and solve
stuff by thinking about them
but it's action it's using them these
Technologies are so complicated they
have to be used in action for discover
both the plus and minuses and that's
what's happening right now with the AIS
is that we've been talking about it for
100 years but it's not until we actually
use them every day that we begin to see
what they're good for and bad for
and so uh and and so this this uh idea
there's there's unintended negatives but
they're also unintended positives as
well right so within within days as we
said of of GPT for going online there's
tweet threads about use cases that
nobody thought of before somebody
figured out that uh you know you could
automatically have a lawsuit filed
against a robocaller like these amazing
like very like you know specific right
small use cases
um that are kind of amazing you know
writing out in handwritten notes an idea
for a website and then chat GPT just
creating that website in minutes so
whatever it is
um
but also we have you know meta launching
or sort of uh you know introducing its
Ai and somehow that immediately Finds
Its way to 4chan when it was supposed to
be guard railed I guess within the
ecosystem of meta like there are these
things that humans do right like whether
whether they're they're malevolent or
just chaos agents you know that right
that despite our best efforts to guard
against find a way right and so
protecting against that causes concern
and I think the deeper concern
perhaps or or or the thing that that I
think myself and other people find
alarming is just the the pace at which
this is happening it's it's a dizzying
pace you know that uh it's occurring so
rapidly that we don't have time to even
get our footing before there's a new
announcement and a new leap in
technology and that gives us the sense
that this is getting away from us a
little bit Yeah well it's not getting
away from us it's barely I mean if you
get into the actual thing we can unplug
these at any time we can sit back
there's very few things that are
completely irreversible and that's one
of the myths about AI is somehow it's
irreversible that it's gonna unleash and
then turn around and kill us and that's
just Hollywood again it's it's a good
story but there's no absolutely no
evidence whatsoever in any direction
that there that it's on a runaway
exponential curve in fact it's the
opposite so so the idea would be that
this exponential curve we get it going
and it's on Unstoppable it becomes kind
of a superpower but
if you actually there is no exponential
growth in the intelligence part of it
exponential growth is in the resources
that we consume to make it so it's
actually the inverse of exponential
growth meaning it's requiring more and
more compute power
to produce a little bit of a gain
so the gain is not increasing
exponential the gain is
pretty linear but but the number of
resources required to make that
increases exponentially so it's actually
self-limiting in in that sense right now
at this time yeah I mean we should
distinguish between narrow AI generative
Ai and then you know the the the the
kind of thing the sexy thing that's
that's out there on the horizon which is
you know General AI which we're nowhere
near at this point right we're in the
sun candy Valley in the way these chat
Bots speak to us that create the
sensation of of you know Humanity or
some level of Consciousness that's truly
Just an Illusion so so it is it does it
is unsettling
yeah so let me acknowledge it is
unsettling it is moving fast but
um it's not out of our control and then
secondly what we're discovering is is
more something more fundamental which is
not that this thing is getting so much
smarter it's just that we're realizing
that many of things that we held as
being highly to achieve turned out to be
fairly mechanical right I can assure
most people you're not going to lose
your job you may lose your job
description
okay and the task in your job may change
some of the tasks may go away but your
job is unlikely to go away so far I
found only one kind of job of one person
one kind of job who's lost to AI
everyone else is going to change it but
but we we have we have time if we pay
attention to it what we don't want to do
is to
prohibit or outlaw or ban these things
because then we don't get to steer it's
only we can only steer these things by
using them and so there's a there is a
tendency to want to well I want to stop
it I want to Halt it I want I don't want
this thing to happen and that means that
no no you're not you're not going to get
to steer the people who actually do use
it somewhere are going to be the one
steering it because we can only steer it
through using it finding out how it
works and the the idea of
um general intelligence artificial
general intelligence I think is is is is
is again it's a myth it's it's not even
real we have no evidence of such a thing
because so far
the kinds of intelligence we make are
very very specific very very narrow and
we have really no idea how our own
brains work we're just we're just
projecting all kinds of things about us
and I think one of the greatest things
that the AI are going to help us is to
help us become more human and better
human
and I'll give you an example the
simplest one which is
um we train these generative AIS on all
the stuff that every all humans have
written all the content all the books
all the writing all the literature and
it's sort of like the average of of
humans
okay and and it turns out that the
average human behavior is sort of ref
right sexist and mean and like we're
outrageous like
we won't accept that
it has to be better than us
okay
we can we can put in ethical moral
guidance into these because it's just
code that's pretty easy
the so we can easily code in ethics to
these AIS and we can actually give them
better than us but the problem is is
that we humans don't know what that
looks like does it mean like you're woke
is it like being super awoke is it
something else is it what what does that
look like to behave better than us or at
our best
where do we get that consensus who is
the who who's the US in this who decides
who thus is there are all these
questions
but but if we can arise and come there
so this is what the best human or the
better human would look like and then we
can code that into it we could make them
and then we would that would help us
ourselves
become better because it's like our
children would make us better people
okay we want our children to be better
than us and so we articulate the best
behavior and they can maybe help us
change our Behavior so in the effort to
actually try and
come up with ethics that are consistent
in deep moral guidance and is that is
elevated for for us we have a chance
to become better humans
sure but that that is a larger problem
than I think people understand because
there is no one in the same way that
there is no monolithic AI there is no
monolithic ethic there is no Right One
Singular value set right you should
drive this right and you know the ethics
or or the values that are important to
the creators of a particular AI it may
not very well match up against the value
set or ethics of another group right so
that's a difficult problem
and those you know whatever whatever is
instilled into that AI in terms of
values and ethics is going to dictate
results so right that's a Sticky Wicket
for sure so so you may have people
favoring one or the other so it's like
the little trolley problem for the
self-driving car I'm going to use I'm
going to use this AI for this and this
for this well no it's like okay you have
a car so should the car prioritize the
safety of the driver or the pedestrians
right did we get down to thought
experiments that are either yeah those
are all philosophical trolley problems
but now we have to answer them we can't
just wave our arms as if we don't answer
we actually have to answer it and so
people will say no I'm going to buy the
car
that that prioritize the safety of the
driver over the past they'll make an
answer the answer is we're going to
favor the the safety of the passenger
over the pedestrians and you can buy
that one because that's our ethics here
so so so we don't again we have given
ourselves a pass the kind of the
inconsistent uh ethics and morality that
we have when we're driving
because we don't know who we favor we
don't have that luxury with the AIS we
actually have to make a decision which
will force us to understand that our own
ethics are very shallow and consistent
so we have to better one and they'll be
as you said they'll be competing ones
and which ones do people
favor right and there there are
Regulatory and and legal issues that are
implied by that right like are you
really enabled to make that decision
that your car gets to favor you over The
Pedestrian who gets to make that
decision exactly
um that's a problem I think the other
wrinkle here is is that that makes
people a little unsettled and maybe you
can speak to this is this notion that
the AIS even as they currently exist the
creators of them can't tell you how the
decisions are being arrived right and I
think that that freaks out a lot of
people it does it does and if we can't
understand that right and we're only at
the Inception right in terms of the
power and capacity of what these tools
are going to be able to Avail Us in the
coming years that's disturbing as we're
tiptoe towards a more General AI version
right what we're now seeing yeah I I
think you're right this this sort of
unexplainability of the AIS is
disturbing it's interesting that we
aren't as Disturbed that the humans that
we deal with can't explain things either
for some reason okay we accept that
right yeah that's perfectly fine but I
demand this is again going this way we
demand our Creations to be better than
us okay and but but secondly to to that
point is there are efforts right now
it's a whole field of AI study called
explainable AI to actually have it
explain it and what it does is it uses
another AI
that's built to reach in and to try to
explain what the AI is doing interesting
and that is of course the Genesis of
Consciousness but isn't it so
complicated that even
should that secondary a I succeed at
that the manner in which it would
communicate to a human being would be so
reductive as to be right not necessarily
even accurate right and that's exactly
the same problem humans have why did you
do that right well we're all clouded by
our emotions of course and we're going
to add by the way just wait till we add
emotions to this which is in the next
couple of years because a lot of people
think though you can't really have
emotions until you have Consciousness
and awareness and stuff
no again emotions is something that's
very primitive like the other things
we're discovering you don't need very
much our pets have emotions we can put
we can put lovingness and being loved
and grad all these things into very
Elementary machines and they're going to
really spook people because
it'd be like her it'd be people who bond
to these things
um in an emotional way like Megan like
Megan and so it's it's like it's going
to be very very complicated but the
thing yeah the optimism within you
remains become daunted because they are
like our children
it's like
yes
and we're like Gods okay we're going to
make these beings
that have free will and choices and we
hope that they surprise us with
amazingly good stuff
but the price that we're willing to pay
is that they may
do something harmful
okay that's like you can't really you
can't generate anything really great
without that possibility of going the
other way and so are we willing to pay
the price to unleash these kinds of
entities that can actually generate new
things
and I think we want to minimize that
harm and so how do we do that with
children
we train them
we we instill them with values we try to
have we try to con we try to move
forward our own values into and so we
are going to train them we don't want to
restrain them and say no no
um the fact that you could do something
wrong means that I'm not going to let
you have make a choice I'm not going to
let you create anything new and so
that's what we're doing with these
machines in order to in order for them
to generate new things that would be
useful to us with us we want to train
them sure and so we want to minimize it
we're not going to eliminate it I got
you but on this idea that we are the
gods we are unleashing this new
technology and we are training it and it
is learning what happens when what it is
learning is how to self-improve itself
and to do that with extreme exponential
rapidity right to the point that almost
instantaneously it becomes the God and
we become the subject and the notion
that we can simply unplug it it becomes
uh you know an impossibility so so I'm
ever I'm with you all the way except for
the exponential part as I said there's
zero evidence of that in fact it's the
other way around it can have thinkism it
can work in its brain but it doesn't
have what what it needs which is what we
are gifted with which is a body to
interact with the world and have impact
so yes it could work in its in this
little mind to go around and around and
get a little smarter
but it's stuck inside a circuit
somewhere to actually have impact to
actually take control to actually have
effect on the world it actually has to
be connected to the world in some ways
it has but isn't it connected to the
World by Dent of being you know wired
into the internet
that does what's it going to do
I don't know what what couldn't it do
well I mean it's like it's connected
right now its impact is the fact that
other people are reading it humans are
are Translating that into the world
they're they're doing it they're they're
putting out whatever it is and so in the
sense that it needs us still needs us
the idea that it can be independent is
um is an abstraction that just
um it's very it's a fantasy that we can
imagine but it it doesn't have any
bearing in the actual real world and the
same thing with exponential we can
imagine exponential growth but there's
no evidence at all of anything being
exponential in the real world right now
and and and to have something that gets
smarter and smarter through his own
training to have some effect on the
world it has to
do something in the world like what's it
going to do what's what's this brain
going to do is it going to like there's
you know it's gonna take over the drones
well how does it take over the drones
what's the what's that mechanism I mean
it's it's gonna like put itself
somewhere I mean it's all it's a fantasy
right I mean it it reminds me of
I think it's is it Nick Bostrom who has
the paperclip paperclip the paper clip
thought experiment it's just it's it's
it's a it's a it's actually like it is a
religious fantasy this belief that the
thing could become like our God it's
like the cargo coat it's like well it's
going to solve all our problems that's
the Ray Kurzweil ideas it gets it and
then we can solve cancer well the thing
about it that's thinkism this idea that
you could solve cancer by thinking about
it just by reading papers you could read
you could have the most genius AI in the
world right now and if it read all the
papers about cancer that has been
published so far it would not be able to
cure cancer
they still need to do experiments we
still have to there's still stuff we
don't know this idea of so Rey and
people like to think and they think well
if I if you have a really loud of
thinking then it can solve problems
thinking is one part of solving a
problem and it's probably not the most
important part
this idea that you call dumb smart and
yes
another it's another problem which is
that these AIS can be really really
intelligent in one area and completely
idiotic another and I think our
frustration is going to be like we see
with chat GPT already it's like how can
you be
so dumb while you're so smart at the
same time in another Direction and
that's because
the engineering maximum is we can't
optimize everything there's always
trade-offs every organism alive today
is not there's no general purpose
Superior organism there's no organism
that's better than any other organism
because they're all being trade-offs for
particular jobs and so if you're really
really fast then you're probably not
very Nimble if you're really powerful
you're not going to really be efficient
and so there's just trade-offs and the
same thing in in intelligence there are
a lot of Dimensions to it it's not just
a single one and there's going to be
like to be really really good at
translating or image generating you're
probably not going to be good as good as
something else that's made for it over
here and so this idea of a general
intelligence
it's it's it's it's ignorance of the
fact that we have no idea
how our own minds work we don't even we
don't have access we can't explain
ourselves
and and yet we've we've come to
understand that we can things can still
be useful even though we don't
understand them it's interesting because
as somebody who is a techno Optimist I
would think that you would anticipate or
expect that
General artificial intelligence is an
inevitability but you seem to be saying
like this is not possible or in the
event that it arises it's not going to
come in the form that we fear I I think
the picture you want to have in your
heads of of thousands of different
species of AIS plural many of them being
created to perform certain functions
like say doing mathematical proofs which
will be amazing to help us do proofs of
scientific stuff
okay they're going to be engineered to
do that and we'll work with them to do
that but the picture of of rather than a
kind of a superhuman god-like thing is
to think about these as artificial
aliens like Spock
they may even be conscious at some level
although most times Consciousness is a
liability we don't want your
self-driving car to be conscious because
it's distraction
you don't want to be worried about
whether that Consciousness is a
liability it's a liability like a binary
function yeah functioning machine and
and yeah and these things are also not
binary they're they're they're
gradations there's little bits of of
things including Consciousness and
intelligence but the way to think of
them is like Spock which is meaning that
they can be very very bright and about
certain things
but they're not human-like
because they're built on different kind
of substrate and that's their benefit is
that they don't think like us and that's
true of the generative ones we see right
now they can imitate us in a bland way
but that's not useful to us and you we
we detect it we are already sensitized
to it it's like no that's that sounds
like a gbt so I call them the universal
personal intern right and you're it's
embarrassing to release the interns work
you want to check their work you want to
work with them they're going to always
be available for doing all kinds of
things
but it's a it's a cooperation it's a
partnership it's a they're co-pilots
they're they're interns their assistants
and
um we're going to use them like we
navigate with the GPS
assistant the Navigator we have
assistant librarian who searches the web
for us now we have the interns who help
us create things and
um that's the current state but what
we're going to is is these artificial
aliens which are really smart but they
they aren't if they're really really
smart in some Dimension they're unlikely
to be smart in another dimension at the
same time because it's a trade-off
because that's engineering and opt like
what would be like the what's the super
organism on the planet
the organism to beat all the other
organisms it's like that's the
nonsensical question you were saying
what's the intelligence that would be
superior to all intelligences
it's a nonsensical question right I mean
we like to think as human beings that we
are the most uh you know Advanced but
you know are we any more adapted to our
environment than the Cockroach you know
you've spoken about this right right we
need to you know recalibrate how we
think about these things and then apply
that mentality to how we're thinking
about AI so in that you know kind of uh
strain of thought would you say that
this is a base level like emergent life
form or intelligence like how are you
thinking about that in the more kind of
like you know sci-fi sensibility for
sure like is there is this idea that you
know we as human beings like the
caterpillar to the butterfly are here to
evolve and that the the the the the
evolution you know will ultimately be
you know to to transform into this new
life form at some point which will not
necessarily be carbon based and maybe
silicon based so I wrote a book called
what technology wants which was
primarily trying to ask this question of
what are the general directions in the
evolution of technology and just as a
spoiler my view of my theory of the my
theory of technology is that it's an
extension of the same forces that run
through evolution in life the same
self-organizing
forces or working through Evolution and
evolution is basically biological life
accelerated that it's kind of like is
attempting to create forms that you
could not get to with wet tissue so
these all these this space of all
possible things that that you need to
have a a mind help you make the Mind
came from what biology but it can make
these things that we could not get to
that the biological evolution would not
get to by itself and so
um what are what's the general
directions and one of the direct Direct
General directions is that we constantly
will specialize that we make
the first life is a general purpose
um cell and now in our own bodies we
have like 52 different special T cells
we have skeletal cells heart muscle
cells we've specialized and that's the
general pattern is you have the first
camera that did everything now you have
specialized cameras high speed cameras
underwater cameras infrared cameras high
speed underwater infrared cameras we
just kind of go and that and same thing
with IQs and AIS we're going to have a
general
kind of general purpose thing and they
will make these specialized versions of
them over time right like the the
general or the the AI as it exists now
being a single-celled organism as
opposed to trying to nurse yeah exactly
and so um and and then the question is
the big question that I have really no
opinion about is whether we humans will
speciate
and it's very possible that
um with genetic engineering that there
will be people say the Amish my friends
the Amish who will decide under no
circumstances will I or any of my
descendants ever modify their genes and
then you have other people it's like
yeah tomorrow
I'm gonna get me into that give me right
take away my take away the Alzheimer's
Gene from I and all my Descendants the
Brian Johnson's out there who are
quantifying themselves to the nth degree
right but but I mean removing you know
really you know Parkinson's Gene I don't
want to have it in me or my kids just
take it out and so over time we might
have two different
or more species we don't know and then
the AIS are again I said artificial
aliens
um and and we'll make more of them and
they'll work alongside of us and that's
to me the reason why I'm optimistic is I
believe that there are problems
that we have right now both in science
and in business or culture that we our
own minds may not be able to solve it's
like quantum gravity whatever it is
maybe our human Minds by themselves
can't solve that but working with Minds
that we make we may be able to solve
sophisticated interns it's sophisticated
interns and co-pilots we together we can
we can figure out some of these things
um to to solve and and that's so I I
look at a future that's filled with
thousands of different kinds of AIS
maybe there's maybe we speciate or not
who knows and um that that world is so
there's not to sort of one big god-like
AI that's kind of afraid of but instead
we have this they're like machines we
have we we don't have one big machine
we've got a lot of machines and it's
like how do you feel about machines
well which machine do you mean my
dishwasher the dishwasher or the car or
whatever it is laptop how do you feel
about AI it'll be completely ridiculous
it's like well which AIS are you talking
about so I think
um
and that kind of uh that's a protopia
yeah not Utopia that's a protopia right
protopia the product of of human agency
and and and and and Innovation uh with a
optimistic bent to it towards progress
and you know positive a positive Better
World the pro comes from proceeding
forward the progress prototyping and the
Pro versus the con so there's there's
lots of of that and um the idea is is
that yeah it's it's um
it's like now but a little bit tiny
bitter right a little bit I think
there's a misguided sense that people
could get that that your perspective on
technology is is Steely and cold but in
fact it's quite the contrary I think you
have a very profoundly spiritual
relationship to
to all of this that I think is
fascinating that that I'd like to
explore and
maybe a way into that is is something
you mentioned earlier which is
the fallacy of the heroic yeah single
inventor this idea that you know the
Einsteins of the world or
um you know these singular people that
we look to who pioneered certain
Technologies and and kind of putting the
lie to that
to that myth and understanding that
there are kind of tectonic plates at
play here where if that person hadn't
done it there was somebody right on
their heels that could have done it and
the idea that that these sorts of ideas
are are kind of percolating in the
collective super consciousness of of
humanity and and maybe even broader than
that so talk a little bit about that
because I think this is super
interesting yeah so so there is there is
scientific evidence and academic
evidence that this idea that most
inventions
the norm is to be invented at the same
time independently by a number of people
and when you look at it it's kind of
shocking the numbers that will come up
with of simultaneous inventions in the
past and of course that's why we have a
patent office today is to kind of
adjudicate that because
[Music]
um
multiple people even even today are
inventing the same things and
um of course the other thing that's
happened recently I'd say the last 150
years is that there's very few single
inventors almost all great things have
teams of people right necessary at this
point and so um so solo genius you know
idea is it's just yeah SOLO genius and
even the solo villain is a Hollywood
Trope this idea of the person in the
cave or top of the mountain who's got
all this technology right that works for
the first time it's like they're by
themselves
it's like come on you're right here
you've got five guys just trying to keep
the it going for this place and so
um so that solo thing is just wrong it's
we're a very communal thing and we're
becoming more mutualistic as we go along
as a society we're much more dependent
on each other for everything and that's
my idea the technium which is that even
Technologies require other Technologies
to live and operate and that that system
of all the Technologies connected
together is has an agenda itself has a
has a impulse or a uh a tendency that's
the technium and I think that this idea
that that um
um it is um we're a much more
mutualistic society and Technologies are
is is um is important for us to
understand
and then one of the I think it works
against one of the worries that people
have of the Rogue
villain the you know the individual who
can
unleash smallpox or
bio-engineered weapon or other things
then it's it's the fact that these
Technologies are becoming more
complicated then that actually is even
Beyond an individual to do again it's a
kind of a fantasy idea but in my
research
um the power of individuals to do harm
has actually not increased through
technology because the Technologies
constraint that because they're much
more mutualistic and social you just
need a lot more people to get things
done so that's again another reason for
optimism
but I do want to say
one thing about the
um we'll call it the spiritual component
of Technology
my
um
my understanding of both the origins of
life and going through the unveiling and
unrolling of Life on this planet and
this creation of minds I think first of
all that
it's happened a zillion times throughout
the Universe other I mean I I take it
for granted that there are other
planetary civilizations and they have
something kind of a similar
Origins and growth but that um
uh the basic
um
the basic Trend the basic Arc that we're
going through that we're following we
that we're part of so that we're part of
something that began at the big bang and
is running through us and would go on
Beyond us and technology is the kind of
current
form of that that we're that we're
involved in and what it does what it
gives us what technology gives us is
Cosmic technology from The Big Bang
through us is increasing choices and
possibilities
I mentioned earlier that you know
farmer until a couple hundred years ago
most people didn't have much of a choice
about what they did with their lives
they were constrained by
the undevelopment to to be Farmers or or
maybe a farmer's wife and to be a mother
and and those were the only choices that
most people for most of human history
have had but we have
discovered this new invention called the
scientific method which Unleashed a
whole bunch of new possibilities that
did not exist before and we're the
benefit of that today you and I were
doing things that 100 years ago nobody
would think would be a job no one would
think would you could
survive on doing
and in the future there'll be people
doing things that we
would not believe would be possible
today and and I think what that means is
is that um the story I like to tell is
is to imagine Mozart having been born
before anyone had invented the piano or
the symphony or anything like that say
born two thousand years ago
that his G his musical genius would be
totally lost on us we would never get to
share it
um and that that's a shame to us and to
him and then there's imagining Van Gogh
being born before we invented oil paints
or
or Hitchcock or Lucas before invented
the cinema so each one of these is our
inventions have enabled that genius to
be
um
to flower and to be shared benefiting
both us and then and that means that
today somewhere in the world there's a
Shakespeare who has been born
and she's waiting for us to develop the
technologies that would allow her genius
to be shared and enjoyed in benefiting
us so we have a moral obligation to keep
inventing these things and and the moral
obligation to get the primary
Technologies of clean water and
education and everything else that also
enable that
and so for me we're on a grand journey
of trying to open up the possibilities
to allow that every person born and yet
unborn would have a chance to
develop their genius to become the only
and to share that with us as a benefit
and that's
that's the big story
that I think we're about and then you
know in that process when people were
making things they're making something
new and they can seem like they're just
worked into the capitalistic consumer
business of making something new that
doesn't work but in fact
they're taking part in this great Arc of
trying to open up the possibilities of
the universe to the people on this
planet yeah it's a beautiful sentiment
you can't help but think well I have two
thoughts you can't help but think
of what genius was lost or squandered
right because
we didn't we had not developed the
appropriate outlet for the expression of
that particular genius over the course
of human history
and then secondarily to that
uh this notion of of of collective
consciousness of almost a hive mind
right like we're all participating
uh on some level in the Gestalt of
Forward Motion in the generation of
these new technologies without really
understanding the context or or the the
broader kind of macro role that we're
playing we're like ants like you know
moving you know along as we're digging
our Aunt you know ant hill or whatever
but we have no awareness of you know the
broader the broader game to play and yet
it is sort of unfolding naturally as if
there was some sort of divine plan at
play or greater intelligence that were
you know consciously unaware of
absolutely and and I well I'd like to
have one other spiritual Dimension to
that maybe coming back to the vice book
and that is that um I think at the heart
of my advice is the fact that this
long Arc this generative thing of
increasing possibilities of the
self-organizing dynamic that it has
another attribute which is a a paradox
at his heart
and that for whatever reason the way the
universe kind of works is that it's
generous at its foundation in terms of
it producing things in its abundance and
it's a probability
and that generosity is captured in this
Paradox of our own human situation which
is that the more you give away the more
you get
which makes no logical sense whatsoever
but it's so reliable that you can live
your life based on that and that that
sense of um
of being able to give away knowing that
you'll get it is the foundation of all
artistic creation
and the best Habit to have because you
need to produce a lot you need to give
away a lot and keep making things in
order to make something great
it's making a lot of bad stuff and if
you are confident excuse me that there's
more where that's come from you can keep
giving that away and that's how you
arrive you understanding of yourself is
that it's it's a it's a generous
outpouring and that you can rely on that
that that you can rely on the fact that
people are going to treat you well if
you assume the best of them you can rely
on things getting better because we're
trusting the future Generations
so there's there's a sense in which
um a lot of my advice about how to
behave is based on this premise that at
the heart of this long Arc and history
of creating more
um possibilities is is a generosity that
we can count on sure and I think that's
beautifully articulated and I'm
certainly you know somebody who who has
experienced that myself and would agree
with you wholeheartedly I think with
respect to the the piece around
Innovation and Technology
where it becomes sort of problematic or
challenging is is around the idea of
whether these Innovations are are
extractive or regenerative or or
sustainable right and we have a long
history of producing innovations that
seem to benefit us but ultimately long
term are too extractive to be
sustainable and are wreaking havoc on
our planet and creates this tension
between progress and this ticking clock
uh where we are quickly depleting the
resources of our planet and not
respecting it uh you know adequately and
so the question becomes can we pivot
away from extractive technology to you
know at a minimum sustainable technology
or perhaps more laudably regenerative
technology so where do you you know
where where does your mind sit around
how we make that pivot because I think
we're
living in in in in a world in which the
systems that we have created have
erected
um a misalignment of incentives that
drives us towards the extractive model
yeah this goes back to I think
we have a loud choice we and
particularly in the politics of things
that is a choice that we can make or not
make and I think we have not yet made
any technology that we can't make
greener
more appropriate but that's a political
will Choice that's a choice right so
technological will is a is a big right
Sticky Wicket problem technologically we
we know a lot of the solutions are we
there's two kinds of problems
in my mind there's there's the um
tractable problems problems that we know
how to solve but just have to choose to
and then problems that we have no idea
how to solve most of these climate ones
are in the first category where we know
what most of the solutions are and so
that's just that's will a political of
choosing to to do those you know we we
know that if we Electrify the current
existing Energy System I mean we we can
consume exactly the same amount of
energy but Electrify it we can reach 50
percent of our climate goals
by electrifying all the stoves
electrifying all vehicles electrifying
all heating electrifying oil
transportation
electrifying everything
just that alone will get us halfway
there
to the current goals and so we know how
to do that electric cars all kinds of
heat pumps and it's the will the
political will to to do it so
um
I would say that that's a category one
problem which is good because it means
that you know how to solve it
right
we have the technology we have the
Capital Solutions but it almost it makes
it more frustrating that we can't
Implement those Technologies like we're
in our own way right because exactly the
systems that we ourselves have erected
right preventing us from taking
advantage of of knowledge that's
accessible already right and so one of
my bits of advice
from the book is that you can't reason
someone out of a opinion that they
didn't reason themselves into so the
thing about it that we're kind of
confronting is that
people
unlike say the AIS are not just very
logical they often
they're very emotional they they arrive
at things for
not logical reasons and they inherit
views they have cultural
standards and Norms that they absorb
even unconsciously it's just they're so
so we're very very very complicated and
we have to kind of operate
at other levels to to change our minds
and
um people who like me who like to think
think that if we can change how people
think
um they'll change their minds but that
doesn't work very well no and we have
the added you know problem of people
being motivated by their own
self-interest yeah
again yeah yeah
and that's true that's human nature
we're gonna so so you have to
um yeah you have to make it work and
that's we're saying some some change in
the electric cars and so electric cars
the reason this is that they're just
better cars forget about everything else
they're just Superior cars in every way
and that alone may help them come about
and become the norm right but then we
have the downstream extractive uh you
know practices in terms of Mining and
minerals Etc to create these batteries
that you know it's sort of like for
every new solution there's a new problem
that we have to address absolutely and
and my protopian viewpoint acknowledges
that that most of the problems we have
today are caused by the Technologies of
the past
all the problems that we're going to
make in the future are going to be made
by the technological solutions
that we have today
and so you say well you know what's the
point well the point is is that actually
we keep increasing the the possibilities
and choices that we have okay that's
that that's what we get out of it so I
agree with the technological critics who
say that that um
[Music]
you know we keep increasing the the
number of problems but um where I where
I differ is I think the solutions to the
problems made by technology is not just
personal virtue it's actually new
technologies who themselves will have
new problems
but um that is the problems that Propel
the problems are just opportunities in
disguise right I mean I theoretically
I'm in agreement with you I I get
tripped up a little bit by the ticking
clock of of yeah environmental
degradation like how much time do we
actually have to solve these problems
before we you know Eclipse a certain you
know point at which uh you know the the
the global kind of climate crisis
becomes so untenable is to be
irreversible like that's you know we
really are up against that right now and
so there's a certain urgency to this
that um I think needs to cattle produce
out of the theoretical mindset into the
the truly practical application mindset
right yes
um and and that unfortunately is is
going to be a very hand wavy deadline
because of our our ignorance
particularly at the planetary scale one
of the things we discovered
not just through climate but um if you
ask any question of the earth of our
society at the level of the planet the
answer is we don't know
and I was involved in trying it was a
failed attempt to try and do a survey of
all the species on our planet because we
don't know we don't know to
I don't know I would say to maybe 50 of
what the actual numbers we we haven't
even identified all the living species
on this planet which is like a it's like
crazy
and so um uh so if you ask any kind of
question the one we know about the most
is population and even that I think
we're 10 off either direction and and we
constantly revising even now the
projections of our own human population
and
um one of the things I am concerned
about is the coming population implosion
after we reach our Peak and we don't
have agreement on when that is but it's
probably within uh less than 50 years
and so um and that's the thing we know
the most about not the planetary scale
and so our ignorance about our own
Planet what's going on and what's
happening right now is is phenomenally
great and
um that's one of the first places that
we should be working on to to you know
stabilize the climate not to mention all
of that being exacerbated by uh a
denigration in the global conversation
and you know a sense of of decorum and
how we problem solve right as we you
know move towards what could what many
consider to be this post-truth world
that's being exacerbated by you know
algorithm social media algorithms and
information silos that are making
communication and problem solving more
difficult which is of course another
unintended consequence of technological
innovation that's right and so
um yeah I mean we're we're we're we're
moving whether we want to or not whether
we acknowledge or not to becoming a more
planetary society and that disturbs
people both on the left and the right
they go crazy all this idea of a global
governance and um yet we have a global
planetary problem that requires Global
cooperation this I'm not going to happen
otherwise and so and so that to me
that's a new phase of our civilization
that we're moving into this planetary
wide level of
um whatever it is that we're making we
don't have names for it and and that is
um truly a frontier
for us as a species that only happens
once in the planet's life when you have
this knitting together of a planetary
civilization it only happens for the
first time once and so um that's what
we're moving into and I think
um we don't have good language good
vocabulary we don't have good Notions we
don't have a good role model
um it's a truly a frontier yeah but
unbridled optimists that you are right
undaunted it's gonna be fantastic and
it's going to be amazing right yes okay
because uh the alternative is what right
okay but uh you know I don't know maybe
I'm injecting a little try to a little
realism into this I don't know I don't
wanna I don't want to like you know rain
on your on your parade I want to be an
optimist I'm like
not everybody can be an optimist okay
because we're in a speeding car as you
mentioned earlier and in order to turn
you have to have breaks there have to be
some people who are breaking it we're to
be able to turn I you're the guy I'm the
engine it's going to be amazing I'm the
engine and I think we need to have a
really an engine has to be more powerful
than the brakes to keep going forward so
I'm I'm glad that there are people who
are trying to break it because we need
them
okay
but my role is to keep making the engine
go more powerful as we go forward I got
you okay
um I got you all right so you're talking
about the global sort of conversation
that we need to have to solve these big
big problems I want to I want to take
that down to the very local you
mentioned uh the Amish earlier yeah yeah
yeah uh this is a community of people
that you've spent quite a bit of time
with your sporting an Amish beard you're
so did the Amish beard come before your
immersion in the community before it did
why is that
I just just when I grew a beer after
high school style I the mustache just
drove me crazy I just couldn't stand it
so I shaved it off and then I discovered
oh the Amish do that maybe they're my
brethren and that's your thing um but
then later on when I became more
interested in technology I became more
interested in technology I mean the
Amish and I went to start to visit them
the first time when I rode my bicycle
across the US I would visit them and I
was I had one major question which is
how do they decide
what technology is to use or not and it
was a it's a very interesting
conversation because they have trouble
articulating that it's so
culturally kind of embedded that that
they haven't really thought about it in
kind of a curious way but that was my
main question and I've and I decided
that they had some lessons for us
outside about our own use of technology
so that's a a culture that's a mystery
box to most people yeah we look at it
and you know we're we're curious we sort
of you know glance at it like we're
glancing at a a car accident as we're
driving down the freeway without really
understanding what's actually going on
but you have spent a lot of time with
these people and what's fascinating is
you've extracted certain principles
around living that are instructive so
talk a little bit about that
from the Amish you mean so the Amish
um okay so so there's a stereotype of
the arm which is they don't use
technology which is incorrect they use
technology but they have um they're very
careful in selecting which ones they use
and they're always not always but they
are gradually
changing that mix and then thirdly the
mix of what did Amish use is really
governed perished by Parish
sucked by sect decentralized so so it's
not uniform and the ones that are most
liberal would say about the use of
Technology are the ones in the Heartland
where the Amish
kind of were centered and began and some
of the more stricter ones are at the
outer edges
of of of that Upstate New York and in
Indiana and so um
um so it varies but the general
principle that they use is they have two
main criteria for deciding whether to
adopt technology in their lives the
first one is will this technology help
me to strengthen my family and the goal
or the the evidence for that is they
want to be able to spend
um breakfast lunch and dinner every meal
with their children until they leave
that's their goal so that means they
want they have one room Schoolhouse
nearby and the kids come back for lunch
means that the
they do business in their Farm in the
backyard or they have a little shop in
their backyard that's their ideal and if
they have technologies that helps them
do that they'll use it so I had some old
order my old order Mennonite friends
with a horse and buggy
the bonnets suspenders the whole thing
but they have in their Barn in the back
they have a CNC milling machine computer
controlled milling machine running
electricity from a diesel and the 14
year old girl in the Bonnet is running
the CNC machine okay because it keeps
them on their family and the second
criteria is does it help uh and breed
our community
as a community so the reason why they
have a horse and buggy is that the horse
can only go 15 miles
in in any direction so while they're
shopping doctors whatever it is that has
to happen within 15 miles so they keep
everything in that Community the
priority the real Focus uh the locus of
that decision making is is it making our
community stronger more interconnected
more intimate or is it fracturing it
exactly and so when a new technology
comes along they have Amish early
adopters
and there are you see guys and they'll
have like cell phones and they're like
beta testers so I need a cell phone for
my business okay and so the bishop says
okay interesting okay Ivan
um you can have a cell phone but you've
got to keep it
um in the shed oh wait you can't have it
in your house
and
um you have to solar charge it and we're
going to be watching you and your family
to see if this is making you stronger as
a family man if this is if you're and if
you're actually more contributing into
the community and if you're not you have
to be willing to give it up
um and so Ivan tries it out and
um they say oh they discover something
about the phone is that his wife
wants one because her sister has now
been moved away to a place in Indiana
and they wanna
keep the family in touch
so basically the Amish are adopting
the flipped cell phone interesting
because all the evidence so far has been
that it strengthens their ability to
have communities
um move apart and live in different
areas because the land is too expensive
in one area and so and and the in the
family business is better so they can
keep in the backyard so they're saying
yes to the cell phone Flip Flip cell
phone
um
now Ivan has a new smartphone he's
wondering about right like that becomes
very diff very sort of challenging right
quickly because obviously you can go on
the internet and perhaps learn more
efficient ways of farming that will
increase your yields or other tools that
could help and the bishop has Community
stronger or you can go down to Twitter
Twitter rabbit hole right you know like
you know spend all your time staring at
your screen and the bishop has heard
these arguments and so they have um
they've Amish computers now
which are computers that
um just do spreadsheets they don't
connect to the internet because they
discover that spreadsheets are really
handy if you're running a business
um and then they have they do have uh
some of them are experimenting with
online where they're like parental
controls
that are public and shared and whatnot
so they can go to certain sites or
they've been using as public libraries
so I I've been meeting this guy gave me
his card for his website and it's like
he's making barbecue um
metal barbecue stuff I said an Amish
website well I use I just get at the
library
I go to the library to pick up my
um mail whatever it is so it's out of
our home and it's at the public library
so that's one solution right
um that's fascinating you know and and
what comes to mind for me and in
thinking about this is again another
tension the tension between the
solutions to our biggest problems lying
in technological innovations and and
really investing in that and on the
other on the flip side of that uh a a
hearkening back to a simpler time right
and when you think about food systems
and the impact of factory farming and
mono cropping and soil degradation
Etc we're seeing this emergent uh
movement around regenerative agriculture
right which is in some ways a throwback
right it is a recognition of a more
ancient practice that is that is more
benefit official for the planet right
um that that is kind of exciting in
terms of how we're rethinking how we
feed the plants Etc
um I'm not sure it's something that can
scale to the level of feeding everybody
on the planet but I can't help but think
how culture is like
the Amish right the Mennonites Etc could
participate and be at the kind of
Forefront of these types of movements I
feel like they have a lot to contribute
yeah in that regard the Amish are really
big and dairy farming because no
ordinary with English Farmer they call
them wants to bother with just too much
effort too much hand labor and the Amish
still have a lot of big families and the
young kids are instrumental in their
Workforce and they're still doing Dairy
but I joke with them that um I think
they're going to be among I think
eventually they're going to accept the
robot milker
which are amazing and would enable them
to continue
um expanding their their Dairy business
as the other English Farmers to give it
up one by one which is happening very
fast because it is very very labor
intensive so I think that might be again
a kind of a weird little thing where
some high-tech stuff in in AI robotics
can help the Amish there's a thing
called Precision agriculture that's
enabled by AI so if you imagine kind of
like a big tractor with uh outstretched
arms that goes down the rows and rows of
lettuces and the um
the the there's a cameras camera eyes
and all the little rows and using AI
the tractor we'll call it can identify
individual lettuce seedlings
by number it can recognize that oh this
is you're 21 52 a I was here yesterday
and it can give the exact it can
appraise its Health give you the exact
amount of water and nutrients or
whatever it needs based on that
individual seedling
using GPS and everything remembers it
and so it has millions of these that is
tending individually
wow that is something the human farmer
would love to be able to do but can't
and yet this Precision agriculture
machine which is being driven by AI is
and that reduces the amount of of
pesticide or fertilizers and water
needed per plant because it's just
giving exactly what that plant needs
interesting that's how AI it can
transform this kind of of um
Agricultural Revolution that we want
yeah wow
um and did you say that that's something
that the Amish are interested in well I
can't imagine the honest you're not
interested in that McDonald's are
interested in this milker the robotic
milk I see okay because that's their
main cash right now for most Amish
farmers is the dairy business because it
is very labor intensive it's working
with animals which they love and it
needs a kind of Hands-On stuff but this
the thing about milking cows twice a day
so here's the cows actually decide when
they get milked that's the beauty of it
they're not being forced it's a it's the
cow are happier because they decide when
they want to relieve and they come in
and get milked automatically and move
out that's like that's everybody's happy
cows are happier there's more milk and
the farmer doesn't have to get up at 5am
and go on vacation every once in a while
that's huge you know it would be better
but we just all stop drinking milk we
don't need to well yeah that's another
what's another discussion thing yeah
um Switching gears a little bit uh I I I
wanna you're somebody and again going
from local now back up to Global you're
somebody who spent a tremendous amount
of time in China kind of we're coming
full circle here
um are in Asia and in particular China
you visited China many many times my
wife is Chinese your wife is Chinese
China is very interesting right now
what's happening there and I feel like
uh it's it's it's a it's a culture and a
place
um that
the Western World doesn't fully
understand so help me understand what we
need to know about China maybe where our
thinking is is sideways on this what we
should be focused on what we shouldn't
be worried about
Etc
wow
um I mean it's a big question that's a
big question it's like you know China is
uh you know is what should we think
about the U.S
um so
um first of all I would say several
things one is I would have had a more
confident answer just three years ago
before covet when I was going living
there constantly I felt I had a pulse on
the country and I felt that um
right now I feel
blind
because I haven't been there and things
are changing very fast since before
covet before we're covered I was there
right before covert my last time and um
so something has shifted
and and I don't have a good sense of
what that is right now so I would say I
would kind of preempt with that that I
feel less confident about that the thing
I would say and it's still true is that
almost anything you can say about China
is true somewhere in China right I mean
it's so fast and there is more diversity
in China than within the US between
California and Maine I mean this is
really vast but one of the things that
people don't appreciate that I will
mention is that um
part of the genius and greatness of the
US was it's built on immigrant
experience of people coming from all
over the world bringing together that
mix up and mash up that kind of hybrid
Vigor of produced by having people from
many different backgrounds try to
contribute and make and be Unleashed and
that hat is happening in China and it
has been happening
but the immigration is all internal
so you have people from very dispared
from Yunnan from Ching Hai from gweiling
coming together and they speak
indecipherable languages to each other
they're except they have this common
language not English but Mandarin but at
home there there are languages and
backgrounds and traditions that are
completely foreign to each other right
and so they're all coming into cities
the young people mixing it up and having
this immigrant hybrid Vigor that we have
experienced in the US and that was
really what was going on for a very long
time I mean for the past 10 years and um
that has been really very very
productive tremendously energetic and
you have cities like Shenzhen where most
of the stuff that we're using for
electronics is made Shenzhen uh in the
80s okay so that's maybe uh 40 years ago
30 40 years ago
was a fishing Village
and now it's a city bigger than New York
City
and it means every single person in that
City nobody was born there
none of the people in Shenzhen 13
million 15 million people were born in
Shenzhen they're all immigrants they're
all coming people out and it's the
youngest city in the world
because they're all everybody's
young there so the youngest hippest city
in the world they've built brand new
opera house and libraries it's a brand
new city the size of New York in the
scale of New York that's brand new so
there is
no matter what happens in China
politically
there is a momentum and a hustle and an
ambition
that I don't think is going to be
squashed by no matter what happens
whether they overthrow things I don't
know but um I'm just saying that there
is a huge
um desire a huge Collective
moving forward that's not going to be
stopped and I don't know where it's
going but I'm saying the the pressure
the volume the intensity of that
is hard to appreciate but we it's not
going to be stopped by whoever's
president or whatever the parties in in
power it can certainly be diminished or
demodified whatever but it's it's really
a billion people on on the March and we
have to kind of acknowledge that and so
um I think that's one thing I would say
the other thing is I asked a lot of the
young people in China constantly
um
who their heroes are
what their dream was besides getting
rich
and the answer was zero zero no Heroes
and no dreams of what they're going to
do so they're racing at a thousand miles
an hour forward
but they don't really know where they're
going that's very strange they don't
what do you make of that so I would go
into dorm rooms
which in the US would at least have
posters of things some something that
they like they're hoping for you know
bands or
something cool whatever something that
would give some idea of what their
interests were they're none of those
they're in China
I I I it means that
um they're ripe for a new religion
there's no Holy Scripture there's no
Constitution there's no sacred texts
there's nothing to guide them so so that
means one is it's a possibility that
could be some weird thing a belief thing
that would go through that many people
would follow
um it means that I think they're hungry
for a vision of where they want to go
there's been a whole thing of the China
dream now trying to get it going but it
I don't know what it is and no one else
does either
um so I would say that that they're ripe
for a belief in something bigger than
themselves but they hasn't been
articulated yet right and is it your
sense that that belief when when it
arises would
sort of challenge the governmental
structure
or uh you know create a situation that
that
you know pits the people against
that's if we'd have to make a bunch of
different scenarios and that could be
certainly one of them here's one thing I
would say about that
I I I would ask these young people in
the big Banquets and stuff maybe they'd
be drinking a lot so let's get some
honesty I say like um what's one thing
that you all agree here on
what's one
belief what's one thing you could all
agree on
that you want
and and they they said um
almost in unison
stability
hmm the cultural revolution and the
craziness the insanity of that is still
close to their parents went through it
and all kinds of stories of all
different ways
um that is so vivid
it's like we'll take it's like we'll
take
almost anything but we don't want
another Revolution right give me a job
something stable they don't want a
revolution so
they're not having a revolution right no
Revolution no Revolution yeah
fascinating
um yes it's it's so interesting and I
and I appreciate what you had to say
about the complexity and and diversity
of of this you know massive landscape of
a billion people
um but I can't help but think of the
implications of a talent pool one
billion people you know deep uh in a
culture in which they've already you
know outpaced the rest of the world in
terms of manufacturing quality of course
and and you know what comes next with
that and you know where where we're
going to be in 10 20. yeah so they have
they have great power and they don't yet
have a great dream I mean yeah so anyway
I mean that's true for many countries
but
um China's moving so fast it has such a
force and a momentum that that could be
dangerous or it could be wonderful
mm-hmm
when you you cast your gaze forward as a
as a future as a futurist yes with
finger quotes
um what does the world look like
20 years from now oh my 10 years from
now do you have a sense of that like
this is your this is your jam yeah yeah
so I I would say several things
I would say it's going to be
more more things will be the same
than change so I think you know 95 of
the world in 20 years now will look like
today
and I think most of the changes are not
going to be in the physical world
um that revolution has already kind of
mostly been completed it'll be much more
an intangible thing of how we understand
who we are like this AI stuff changing
our our beliefs about ourselves and how
we connect with each other so I think
it'll be kind of more in a social Realm
um I think the thing after smartphones
are the smart glasses
but I've been saying that for right I
mean you were a big VR guy and you you
well in the 80s yeah yeah so so like
your timeline on that yeah exactly I've
been wrong for so long you've been right
about a lot of stuff I would say you you
were wrong about that yeah right so so
so take that like you know I'm just
still wrong
um and even lately with meta's big bet
on VR AR and the metaverse and all of
this right and then as soon as Chachi PT
hit like nobody cared about it exactly
so so I've been wrong before on that um
but but that's actually I mean that's
still my answer about what comes after
the smartphone and
um I think that uh
I'm hoping that most gas cars have been
replaced and I'm hoping that we have
electrified
at least the developed countries by then
and I hope that um if we're lucky we may
have the very first glimmers of of
fusion
synthetic solar which is what it is
um and
um
uh
uh I uh you know
um other things I'm hoping again the
general Trend to
less violence in the world means that
there's less
um conflicts overall on average
and that continues in that direction
um
so uh and then you know the Wild Card of
of China but there's always India which
is going to exceed China in a number of
um people and um
what we're seeing
India is the thus diaspora of India is
going to be a fundamental thing as we
can see even tech companies in the U.S
the percentage of them being led by uh
Indian Americans is phenomenal and and
that may be one of the great exports of
India is technical people around the
world yeah and so um I think there's a
there's a huge export of of Indian uh
culture as well yeah exactly movies
television music and we saw it at the
Oscars this year and you know I think
it's you know that's going to continue
yeah the three r's are are you've got in
the song and it's just an amazing I
watch these just they understand or the
three three idiots if you haven't seen
that it's a must-see one of the biggest
in Hindi uh Bollywood movies so um so so
I would say that would be another thing
I'd say maybe more of a influence of
India on on the world stage what's a pie
in the sky idea though that you're
playing around with like all of those
predictions are fairly grounded I think
but what's what's a more harebrained
thought that might have occurred to you
where we'll think things might go that
that well this is again this is maybe a
hope I'm hoping that we really do have
lab-grown meat
available uh animal cell based I mean
cellular yeah cellular whatever clean
meat I keep changing the term yeah
whatever it is you know what it is
um I'm hoping that that is commercially
available in many many different
varieties by then
um as someone who um doesn't eat mammals
and so
um I'm really looking forward to that
yeah I mean I think that's an an
inevitability it's just a it's a cost
thing right now the technology exists
it's commercially available in
restaurants in Singapore in a limited
way it's too expensive but the
technology like they're they're
continuing to iterate on that pretty
rapidly and it's just it's just a matter
of scale I think well in theory but to
me that's a pie in the sky because I'm
interested in not just replicating the
existing animals but actually making up
whole new super Meats
um out of out of uh extinct animals eat
the mammoth this goes back to you
Mammoth Burgers your species project
right like you want to you want to have
a woolly mammoth Burger yeah why not oh
man yeah I'll stick to my plants uh I do
think I do think it's it is it is
interesting what's happening in that
space and yeah yeah there is a uh you
know a consumer acclimation
phase that we have to go through because
people are
um
I think it they have a a certain
reaction to that yeah but I think over
time we'll we'll go away but you know
right now it has to be I'm ready for it
and I'll pay a little bit extra for it
so I'll be one of the first customers
and I have been trying them in the in
the Silicon Valley ones and have you
tasted it or I've tasted several but not
not actually the the beef or the mammals
I've tasted fish and
um cheese milk products but not
um the actual meat
um
and and hamburger is easy to do because
it doesn't have the structure but to
make a steak it's a right to mix those
two is really have been able to do so
far but they're working on it and uh you
know I'm looking forward to it a lot of
money and a lot of smart people are on
that problem
um what are the things on that note uh
that you think we're gonna look back on
I don't know 50 years from now 100 years
from now and just just cringe yeah
it may be eating meat might be one of
them I have another idea which is kind
of maybe trivial but I thought it was
very possible which is that um it may be
embarrassing for us who have names
assigned by our parents yes I I saw the
New York Times article where you had a
list of these things and that one
definitely popped out because it's like
arranged marriages it's like yeah of
course you're going to choose your own
name when you're 16 or whatever it is uh
I wish we all did that
um and the idea that you have a name
assigned by your parents I think it's
going to be embarrassing right that's
that's very interesting I mean that I
feel like that's a sort of progression
or Evolution beyond the gender yeah
conversation that we're having right now
like in natural exactly right of that
yeah
um
you added to that wrapping food in
plastic that's a no-brainer
um getting off the summer from school
yeah we're just going to be educated
Around the Clock why not I went to this
one school where the teachers were not
allowed to teach you anything uh-huh
except how to learn so yeah I think
that's uh well you should be taking your
vacations when you want to rather than
just in the summer so it doesn't mean
you go to school all year it just means
you don't have to take all vacations
together well I think these Technologies
uh are are so powerful and our education
system is so lagging in terms of
acknowledging the power and the capacity
for these Technologies to revolutionize
how we learn and what we learn like
we're learning the wrong things we're
not learning the things we should be
learning and we're not
um training young people to Leverage The
Best of what technology has to offer in
order to really you know kind of nourish
their education exactly and I have one
word YouTube
YouTube is this I can go both ways it's
phenomenal under appreciated the way in
which it's accelerating our culture and
the role as playing in education today
and it has great potential to be even
more I'm an accelerant and I don't think
they even know they being at YouTube
don't even realize what they have and
the part of the problem is that unlike a
bookstore or a newsstand we can go in
and see
what's being covered there's really no
way for anybody encountering it to have
any idea of its depth and breadth
and it's this vast ocean
that is kind of subterranean and people
don't even understand the the way in
which it's working on learning and
accelerating
um all every feel from brain surgery to
uh science it's it's really incredible
yeah I I think we're we're ripe to see
tons more Innovation yeah absolutely
absolutely
um and uh you know kind of pivoting back
to the advice piece uh Before I Let You
Go I did want to touch on one last thing
which is this thing that you did a while
back where you live your life for six
months yeah uh as if you were going to
die and this became the subject of uh uh
This American Life podcast so explain a
little bit about like what you did why
you did it and and kind of what you
learned from that experience
um well first of all I told the story on
when the first America this American
lives and I never told it before and
I've never told it as well since so I
would urge people to go before we'll
link it up it's called it should have
been dead but the the the
um the short version was that I got this
assignment after a religious conversion
in Jerusalem to live as if I was going
to die in six months
and and actually take it seriously so I
suspected knew as a healthy 20 year old
that I wasn't probably going to die but
I had to
really take it and prepare to do it and
that's what I did and
um it took six months and I was riding
my bicycle across to my end date and I
was surrendering the future the entire
time and not taking pictures because who
needs pictures in three months and that
um stripping away of my future
was really important because when I
didn't when I was reborn on the next day
after the six months I suddenly had my
future before me and I and I realized
how important it was to have a future
forward how how necessary and Humane and
how inhumane and torturous it was to be
stripped of a future and that kind of
instigated my interest in exploring the
future and really trying to develop it
because I think it's an essential part
of being a human being is to have
something in front of us
yes how we contemplate how we think
about the future how we plan for the
future and just conceptualize it really
is part and parcel of what makes us
human and is part of the motor or the
motivation for getting up in the bed you
know out of bed in the morning and
planning how we're going to live exactly
right and um we have
in addition to being given these
incredible bodies that were given time
and time only moves forward that is the
future and so it's not only do we have
this incredible blessing of being able
to be put into things that have impact
that we can actually have impact unlike
being intangible beings of light we have
things that we can do and make and get
hurt and hurt others and help others and
build stuff but we also get the time we
get the arrow time going forward knowing
that we I'll have time and a future and
that to me is the great the great ride
that we're on
the angels in heaven are Weeping to see
us squander it yes take advantage yeah
on the subject of squandering it I mean
I think the human mind is is you know uh
oriented around
conceptualizing the future in in the
context of self-interest or optimizing
self-interest and also isn't great about
pondering the future uh in a long-term
sense but more in a short-term sense and
and long-termism is something you've
thought a lot about you care a lot about
and I think is something that's also
percolating up in the culture and
becoming a bit of a Zeitgeist thing
where more and more people are talking
about the importance of thinking about
and approaching our problems from an
extremely you know long lens point of
view right it's it's a taking a kind of
a civilizational scale or a generational
scale is what we like to put about it
thinking in terms of generations maybe
working on something that might not be
finished in your own lifespan that might
require generations to complete like
Cathedral or a road system or something
Grand like that and
um but even Beyond those kind of grand
plans what we want to do is to kind of
help people like ourselves become good
ancestors to to actually
have do something so that in the future
they may say hmm thank you ancestor for
yeah having started that or done that in
the way that most of what we surrounded
ourselves here has been built by
previous generations and we should thank
them so what can we do to be a good
ancestor
besides playing a tree right and what is
the answer to that for you
um
try trying to increase learning in the
world so that we can unleash
opportunities for the maximum number of
people born and yet unborn so that they
can share their genius with us and
themselves beautiful
I think that's a a great place to land
the plane for today I have a million
other things I I could have talked to
you about today I'd love to have you
back in the meantime excellent advice
for living wisdom I wish I'd known
earlier is uh is your new book everybody
check it out this is like the perfect
book to just you know basically open to
any page and have a thought for the day
um I love it and uh you're a National
Treasure thank you a Global treasure
international treasure a cosmic treasure
okay Cosmic treasure yes uh you're a
gift uh you're you're somebody I've I've
followed you for a very long time and
like I said at the outset I was nervous
to meet you because yeah I've been very
invested in the work that you've done
for many years so it really was an honor
and a gift to have you here to share
with me too it was my pleasure I enjoyed
every minute you're a great interviewer
I just love your presence thank you for
being you I appreciate it thank you
Kevin cheers peace bye plants